so black screen and then you hear a
Deadpool's voice okay what does Iron Man
do best but he creates villains so the
whole separation from the rest of the
Avengers was an illusion by Mysterio
yeah to screw with Peter and make him
feel increasingly isolated vulnerable
weak just a mess with this kid welcome
back to new rockstars I'm Melina and
this is rogue theory today we're gonna
explain why
spider-man left the MCU in universe
because they've got to figure that out
too
so we're not business at all according
to plan inside of their plan what really
on today's episode we have of course
Eric Foss episode we have some rogue
theories about Ironman also this is very
fresh actually there's talks that he
might actually find his way back in the
MCU and we'll explain how later and give
you some theories but first spider-man
leaving the MCU is a hoax it was planned
they're doing it on purpose
well if I don't hold the table down it
flies away I want you guys to go down
the line and just explain why they would
do this on purpose yes what story maybe
it might they be trying to tell that is
going to take advantage of the fact that
he could go over to the Sony version of
the spider-man universe and then
potentially even come back a few years
down the road so for the purposes of
this that's gonna be our kind of guiding
light they're doing it on purpose yeah
now why what story they trying to tell
right alright okay so just picture black
screen right and in turn a sound like
pictured in your mind podcast listeners
that's exactly
[Laughter]
ahead of the game so black screen and
then you hear a Deadpool's voice pushes
the black screen out of the way and is
and he makes a direct reference to
spider-man but he can't say it so every
time
spider-man is being referenced he bleeps
it or sensors it over their face right
and he is basically trying to take he's
pitching himself to the Avengers to take
spider-man's place by the way we are now
introducing rogue ease tracking you
might get one you've already earned
because he's the opposite of spider-man
like spider-man is sweet they the
Avengers have spent like what a bunch of
movies protecting him and trying to keep
him out and he earned his way in through
acts of like kindness and valiance
whatever that word being valiant and
like showing that he has judgment and
like coming into his own sucking up
never do that so the art the story arc
for his character is like okay like
learn how to humble yourself you're not
the [ __ ] right that you think you are
and does he get in does he not is like
the new Avenger and also he can do it in
a comedic way by directly referencing
this do you love than you are
specifically saying that the part where
this is on purpose and by design is
because they were like how the hell do
we bring in that pool exactly well
Deadpool can is the one that has
directly you can see through that fourth
wall and you know it the whole Deadpool
movie in MCU phase four or five could be
like a parody of spider-man homecoming
what Deadpool is just the outside to be
like just let me be on the team
materialise I get one block all right I
could have given you more but you said
it yourself you only get one I have so
many roadies sounds like a great rogue
theory on its own yeah alright I'm into
it they they're doing it just so they
yes figure out how to bring it Deadpool
I like it alright Joe were thee reason
it's gentle son can you steal this Rogi
I definitely think I I think I know
exactly what's going to happen the
reason you gotta know cuz I know where
they want to go with the next spider-man
movie is I'm gonna spit is so the first
one was homecoming the second one was
far from home part three spider-man
there's no place like home
what okay no it is and this is where
it's a world he now he's public cuz
that's where it was kind of less left
off that everyone knows who he is but
guess what when he tries to go to the
Avengers they're not there they don't
exist
and the only other superhero is this
lame one called venom so he has to like
team up with venom to figure out what's
going on and that's why I think
eventually they kind of realized that
they're in another like universe
multiverse and that's where the Miles
Morales multiverse comes in and then I
think a live-action or animated oh it's
gonna be Framed Roger Rabbit
and then at the very end I do believe at
some point he's gonna like tap his
little red slippers together their boots
like there's no place there's no place
like home
and then he enters a new universe and
it's all black and white
and there's all the Marvel characters
and then he looks at Iron Man and
because it was black and white he's in
the Wanda vision yes I think the mouths
moralis multiverse and the Wanda vision
multiverse stuff I think is all going to
somehow connect them so the one key word
there is Wanda know his multiverse yes
that's what you're saying is they are
making it a purposeful the whole point
of this thing is so that we force him
into the multi exactly you separate it
and they're like oh no oh no but they
knew all along it's gonna come back to
now pop quiz here on your own Theory how
did he get to another dimension
I think clearly something maybe I think
it's gonna go back to like Wanda
whatever Wanda did and Wanda's getting
some kind of powers I think there's some
kind of incident that sends her back to
that fifties world yeah and whatever
that incident is like a no more mutants
type of incident like thing that she
does is probably then as what affected
him as well yeah gotcha so she Wanda
Maximoff fisca has done something that
has created not only the the ability to
go to a multiverse but she sent some
people there just right out of yeah
yes and the only person who can fix it
is Doctor Strange and the multiverse oh
man I didn't like the Doctor Strange
multiverse of madness but you'll keep it
for now
he's said it as Rob Zombie's saying the
name of that movie maybe it was like a
wrote his own reaction to his own
sentence yeah you shouldn't laugh at
your own what question mark at the end
so far okay two roadies out there I
would like to bid marinas and Jeff's row
keys on my establish the rule just by
declaring that you know you fake it till
you make it
sure sometimes you can't do I suggest
that just for suggesting well so let's
just look at the situation here it does
not make sense for Sony to walk away
from this doesn't make sense for Disney
to do it this way so yeah I think there
is some kind of narrative at work there
at least on a retcon opportunity for
each of these sides to say you know what
we wanted this to happen and I think if
you look at it from Sony's perspective
they have what I think is one of the
best villains in any superhero movie at
least on the Marvel side in Mysterio no
villain other than that us arguably has
really been so successful at deceiving
and getting under the hero's skin so
what if the third spider-man movie
whatever its home wrecked home broken
far from home part three it's great it
begins right where the post-credits
scene of far from home leaves off where
spider-man is now a public menace public
menace and we he lives on in his life
and he's a fugitive he can't go home
anywhere no one will shelter him he's a
fugitive he has to be homeless hey
that's another opportunity put halfway
through that movie of being a public
pariah we see some
then just off about this world something
glitches there's like four Ned's this is
the the next movie this is the sony oh
yes this is a sony spider-man 3 like
spider-man 3 homeless and hobo we
haven't seen any no ninjas as shown up
but four nets and then Peter realizes
wait is this all a freakin illusion
still tattoo Peter is still under a VR
headset or some kind of drone create
illusion it were still in the timeline
of far from home where he's in that
final battle with Mysterio still under
Mysterio's illusion so the whole
separation from the rest of the Avengers
was an illusion by Mysterio to screw
with Peter and make him feel
increasingly isolated vulnerable weak ok
so but but do let's go ahead and like go
into a little further so I what happens
he he now has to like actually defeat
Mysterio dude the whole film right now
the entire second half of the film is
just an extended version of that
Mysterio illusion montage from far from
home he's in this dream world hellscape
yeah constantly wondering what is real
what isn't he's spilling secrets to the
people he shouldn't talk to now because
this is still in the Sony world right it
is people like Ned it's MJ it's his
teacher its Flash Thompson it's on May
it's new spider-man villains like Doc
Ock like Green Goblin
there's the logic part of it of why they
would do it right where there's
illusions of all these new characters
like where were you this whole time
Fantastic Four well didn't I that's
right
but where were you venom whatever and
then also where are the Avengers and
it's because it's an illusion have
interest friends to help him he has to
fight them by himself and then
after this movie is over we reveal that
the deals back on and then he can appear
in these other things because I believe
in magic now I have a question though
does it
are there are we gonna see what's
happening outside of your contractual
reasons no he won't even really
mentioned the fact that anything is
different even definitely will not say
Avengers yeah so that means you're the
guys your home movie is just a dream I
don't knock it off it's plausible theory
it's rogues really gonna go it's like no
one acknowledges at this Anthon like
your idea if you could see the outside
where MJ the real MJ and that little
glue shows people like when they were
all fighting they're trying to rescue
him and it's like conception time so
like everything's happening in a longer
time coasters covering a hole in the oak
a so let's hear them back again in the
form of a tweet basically we okay
Deadpool takes spider-man's place gotcha
mine is Wizard of Oz meets wand vision
hashtag I'm bad at weeds
he's not even reference let's give you a
second take on that spider-man goes down
the yellow brick road to Wan Division
got through the hash tag through the
multiverse yes mine is one friend
spider-man three Mysterio matrix give it
to marina because hers has the Deadpool
one and in fact I'll give her another
one three two one
so that was a negative three point swing
the rules I had to make an example
because we had established the rule
there was a warning
exactly and three two one and this is
actually how high the stakes are if you
guys are wondering it where this is all
headed these point totals will continue
to change as the game goes along but our
players have some stakes that we I'm not
telling you but if they win they get
very special prizes that involve all
something you have to do this is all
very fun so we'll see which of you wins
and which of you gets your wish to come
true and the other two what how much
money you lose
oh yes my rowdy number speaking of how
friends I have our back financially
thanks to these sponsors
and we're back I was informed during the
break that we don't have sponsors for
this episode so it's costing us four new
hips for every guy's eye they're not
cheap it turns out yeah really health
care in our country doesn't make it
cheap you know I get on Medicare guys
it's great oh cool a good advice maybe
that's how Robert Downey jr. somehow
maybe did he survive the events of
endgame or what okay there's a rumor
that figures on the table Robert Downey
jr. not yet okay Robert Downey he will
be back in the MCU but specifically in
the Black Widow movie okay so as a
reminder the Black Widow movies so far
what we know about it is that it
probably is taking place in at least two
timelines pre the events of Iron Man
before we got to know Black Widow at all
and she was presumably under some sort
of elite Russian training or something
or she's already working as a Russian
spy and also post-civil war one there's
kind of been that breakup between Tony
and cap and those teams and she was on
caps team and they have to go
underground
but before infinity war so in these two
timelines are the most likely places we
might see them but Iron Man or Robert
Downey jr. in a weird cameo there's a
rumor that he's gonna show up in these
in what a scene or maybe more I want to
know how you guys think he'll show up
I got it okay so what do they say
we know yeah you mentioned two different
timelines one will be probably mid-2000s
to show this Budapest incident yeah what
was Tony Stark doing around this time he
was not yet Iron Man he was not yet
kidnapped by the ten rings and had to
build his own suit and come out this is
an enlightened selfless peacekeeper he
was a jerk he was
holic he was drinking on the job
constantly he was after a couple
whiskey's gonna have a lot of toilet
paper squares here's the deal
he was arms dealer he was making weapons
of war selling them all over the world
didn't know what hands they ended up in
so what if part of the plot of Black
Widow
involves some weapon and end up in the
wrong hands a terrorist group
taskmaster might be part of the story or
will be part the story but what if this
group this crew that will include Black
Widow Yelena Bulova the the red Guardian
played by hopper a little bit and you're
gonna have this crew of people who have
to work together whatever this this
conflict is what if one of them has to
call up Tony Stark or find him 2006 when
Tony Stark was arguably a very
interesting person you get the hero just
kind of an [ __ ] super rich but super
rich kind of a terrorist when you were
drunk you designed to this crazy missile
nuke and we need to know how to diffuse
it can you help us out he's on the other
engine over here some girl is like
excuse me how do I get out of your house
he's turning to Rick Morty my name is
Alexey whatever your name is
okay just find the green wire and don't
touch it
forgot you found it and pretend I never
existed and basically just dump the
whole thing in RC Cola and and maybe
that'll help and they're like you've
been no help and then he just says f off
he's basically a Wolverine and
first-class so his whole scene is relief
but it's a Marvel movie so a Robert
danger news face has to be the largest
thing in the poster stupid disembodied
voice over phone are we doing D aged oh
we gotta do
digitally added yes like the Superman
one but it's they have so much footage
of them from 2008 they shot that movie
in 2007 they can just use some an app
footage and and if they shoul swap it on
a little boy who helps scar a Scarlett
Johansson defuse a new all right so
you're mostly a cameo relief but
specifically connected to his arms Delia
intended her - for this monster has come
into into goodness and selflessness
gotcha alright that's great Jeff what do
you got I mine is similar that in which
he is comic I feel he's going to be
comic relief because let's be honest
what does starting now everything before
no but what does Iron Man do best but he
creates villains he creates villains
Iron Man - he is the reason why whiplash
happened Iron Man 3 Killinger Mysterio
everyone knows in civilian Kilian yeah
oh that's from Venture Brothers anyway
but then and a Spider Man pretty much
every vote just all and all of the
lackeys all worked for he creates
villains so I feel that yes yeah if he
had not been around how many like movies
would not have army at the end of
Avengers and that's how the absolutely
was yeah yeah he's created almost every
problem brought this on yourself that
has happened oh the the Baron Zemo
happened when crashed into which which
was obviously Ultron is completely a
Tony exactly so I feel yeah i feel of
course this one he has to be the reason
this next villain comes about for Black
Widow who they say is going to be test
master so I believe maybe this is around
like
kind of like post-civil war she's like
doing some kind of underground
undercover thing following taskmaster
before he is taskmaster or she and and
then of course this person goes to Tony
for some kind of arms deal and he's just
like I don't need you I can do it all
myself
and you know black widows listening and
she's like Tony what are you doing
and then taskmaster becomes all evil and
then she's like great now I have to deal
with this who was Iron Man - he also had
he's like a fish man but I want to hear
you're Tony Stark against Eric's Tony
Stark really quick from your films I've
been doing all myself cuz I'm awesome
no one awesome actually calls you to
text you can do my pepper can take your
peppers oh wow yeah it's just a fact
that yours is too clearly just Rick okay
so he just shows up just to cause the
problem exactly a lot of eye rolling let
me tell you Jeff got a rookie alright
Marino dia okay mine is none of that
okay thank you Jeff thank you okay so
essentially the entire block what a
movie happens and we and the movie ends
right of course with you know obviously
spoiler warning foot shoe sure her death
and we go to credits okay like movie is
over movie is done then post credit
scene okay post credits are post post
credits yeah the middle one or the end
what it's the end one okay so you have
to sit through the whole credits because
people work really hard on movies you
guys yeah there are billions of VFX
artists you have to sit there okay
I mean people on their phones in the
theaters during that time but it's fine
uh so it's post post credit scene to
trick people into thinking like yeah
this is it this is it for this character
okay that is when Tony Stark rolls in
and he reveals that he has figured out a
way in his snap like in Tony snap okay
he went into this alternate universe or
like his the soul zone or whatever it
was like when you're yeah when you're
there you're in that realm and also you
know the afterlife the afterlife might
appear different to different people so
it's Tony's afterlife so he spends time
in there and he the one thing he wants
to do is he's like look I saved
everybody and I'm happy but I want to
figure out a way to bring Black Widow
back because she sacrificed herself for
everybody so like here's the deal like
all die I did it like I'm making a
sacrifice okay like I'm super dead right
by want to make this trade and he either
like make some negotiation where he
spends like a billion years suffering
and like he's about it now cuz he's
evolved toward Tony Stark and he's no
longer selfish like in the previous
movies and the very end of the
post-credits is that he figures out a
way and BlackWidow wakes up in the pool
of vessels like Bora where Gamora like
the Boromir pool
yeah the were mere pool yeah Adult Swim
yeah it's basically she wakes up opens
her eyes and I'm like yeah the movie
actually ends resurrects here's a way to
bring her back
permanently and conveniently we didn't
exactly explain how you know Rogi on
this yes what if it's like Doctor
Strange type thing he goes up to
eternity and says eternity of
to bargain right huh something right so
we offers he offers doing some service
for eternity through like different
cosmic dimensions he's like if I do this
for you I get to bring back yeah I don't
need to go back to earth I'm done I've
said goodbye but I get to bring back
someone who has unfairly had to die yeah
to live on in MCU films so that they
don't lose all of their heroes okay yeah
maybe maybe you'll get a Rogi on this
good support if you can support that
idea in your Robert Downey jr. coming to
Bergen okay okay
do you want to be the eternal joy what
is it mortal okay so my name is super
Tony Stark and I'm definitely Tony Stark
get out okay like look at my facial hair
okay okay and like remember how natasha
romanoff died like remember that
remember that yes okay that was [ __ ]
like just just saying that was super
[ __ ] right oh man but like I cause I
basically created every villain ever so
like I deserve to die but like what she
didn't like can I can I like can we just
agree on that part at least do you want
brunch again Jeff you're gonna get that
version of Iron Man because I have the
best Iron Man I'm gonna need you for non
podcast listeners to make it so we don't
have to blur your stack thank you so
much okay Eric let's hear yours in a
tweet again so my pitch for how Tony
I could show up in Black Widow and what
role he'll play pre Iron Man Tony Stark
drunkenly fumbles this way to not help
one bit on the edge of a modern mine is
[Laughter]
okay Tony's dead Tony Stark
snaps his way to bring natasha romanoff
back by tricking an eternal being into
brunch and then is so so good actually I
think they have to use that thing of
like Tony Stark comes it just causes
problems I'll say it's mixed a little
bit with Erics where I think it's gonna
be that gross version of Tony Stark and
it is maybe even still a cameo but then
the ramifications so Eric you still get
more a quarter we don't have to blur
that it's fine more gay for me which is
oh yeah or heart yeah but the game is
not over yet
what because we've got this week one row
question okay and I mean it could really
change it all let's do a quick point on
a brief recap
I have one two three four rogue blocks
I've got five bogeys I have two and a
half Rho GZ no less you ever one more
row geez among all of my baby vas sees
on Twitter to tweet your reviews no
there's no internet vote there is it no
you earn your points here I spent so
much money to trademark baby boxes
you're making money off of so we'll make
this just so Eric can stay relevant well
this will be worth up to for up to so
there's okay so alright here's your
question
guys September 21st yes is Batman day
okay as you know yes each of my right
ones Ironman day May 29th July 4th okay
guys what's the best way to celebrate
Batman day for for roadies going on the
streets and punching a criminal in the
face okay
becoming your own city's Batman
temporarily for one day vigilante and
you maybe just assumed who looks like a
criminal and punch them in the face yes
I just think the whole Jay everyone has
to talk like this that's pretty good
it's great
you get afflicted with a terminal
illness and get the entire city of San
Francisco to pretend Oh
all of the roadies she doesn't even
wanna be that's the one that made a kid
a dime kid joke joke it was just saying
oh that must've been a really great day
you want to take away it being special
for him and give it to everyone else
who's healthy and well I don't recall
saying that all right so on those I'll
give I really like the idea of all of us
having to to go you specifically Eric
stack and then Eric you can have one
back alright so then I'm purposely going
to make sure that yeah that it affects
you cool so then that means that the
winner of today's episode is Jeff one
two three four five six point two five
and Jeff's wish that comes true this
episode is marina sorry
no marina wish Eric no way to make this
through your cards Jeff says I wish for
Eric to talk like the like Yoda for the
rest of the episode guys thank you so
much don't worry there is a quick
question I always ask Eric Eric what do
we got coming out on the channel this
week breakdown of license plates and far
from everything I will do what does that
lead to
that's also it's a path to the dark side
[Laughter]
um you can listen to my weekly podcast
comic-book queers visit me on instagram
I'm at Comic Book queers cool and Marino
can find you I'm on Twitter at Marina
masters and with Eric in that video we
can see your neck Melina you can find me
on Twitter and Instagram
Apple Malina make sure to get this show
as a podcast because this is probably so
weird
in just a few hopefully this episode
with all these voices but it also comes
out there first and then also make sure
to follow new rock stars at new rock
stars everywhere so you can find out
when these license plate videos for
coming thanks so much for going rogue
with us
[Applause]
[Music]